sunday wasn't a good day for the
san francisco 49ers monday was even
worse how about this
jimmy garoppolo out indefinitely with a
high ankle sprain aggravated that injury
on sunday in seattle
george kittle out eight weeks
with a fracture in his foot and then
on the uh on the field quan alexander
traded by the
49ers to the saints for linebacker kiko
alonso and then separately on the west
coast
the la chargers sent desmond king to the
tennessee titan so it was a very very
busy news day yesterday in the nfl with
the 49ers dominating the headlines and
this jimmy g injury chris look
we talked about this when he was back
playing before he was clearly healthy
and it was a question of
impaired jimmy g versus healthy nick
mullins or cj beathard
and you go with impaired jimmy g but the
problem is the longer
you risk playing a guy who's clearly not
a hundred percent from a high ankle
sprain
you run the risk it's going to get
injured again
and that's what happened and now he's
down and he's going to be out for a
while
and it's going to be nick mullins or cj
beathard kyle shanahan was deciding week
by week which guy would be number two
based upon the matchup
i haven't seen any clear answer as to
who's going to start
come thursday night against the green
bay packers and yes the next train is
already on the tracks for the 49ers
right
this is this is as bad as it could be
right now they're four and four
they've shown flashes but they got four
losses
they've lost to two of the three teams
in their division they have to play all
three of them again
and yeah here come the green bay packers
on thursday night
sensing an opportunity to make amends
for a couple of ugly losses that the
49ers pinned on green bay last year yeah
well yeah they're gonna want payback
certainly
the 49ers you know they match up really
good with the sam
i mean the green bay packers they really
do i mean they
they could probably do some of the
things that we saw dalvin cook and
company do
but i mean it's unbelievable i mean it's
i don't ever remember a team
losing this many star players or this
quality of a team a super bowl contender
you know the x you know super bowl
runner up
i mean it's just remarkable the amount
of big names
throughout the year i mean debo samuel
raheem moster you know
bosa ford richard sherman jimmy ward
jaquisky tart
of course jimmy g you know tevin coleman
was hurt
i mean it's unbelievable let alone
there's other guys that there were young
players that they were
helping they we're hoping it could help
out this year i don't know i i look at
it
you know without debo samuel and i don't
know how long that'll be before he gets
back because they know he's got a
hamstring tweak
but no kiddle that's a huge blow and i
think we're getting to the point where
yeah
the 49ers i expect them to be
competitive
i expect them to be in the playoff
conversation i don't know if i
i i probably would say sit here right
now i don't expect them to be in the
playoffs i just think it's too much to
overcome and especially with the
schedule they got coming
and then just the final straw of losing
kittle i just think it's a huge blow
but you know the thing about the 49ers
this year every time we write
them off what do they do what do they do
they stun us with some sort of
master level four-dimensional chess game
plan that your guy kyle shanahan puts
together
and makes it look easy and then when we
start buying in
and you know breaking out the 49ers
colors and wearing the hat and
foam finger then they look like crap
like they did on sunday against the
seahawks so you just never know what
you're gonna get from this team
and and in a weird sort of way when you
look at
how flat the packers were on sunday they
eventually woke up and made it
interesting but short week back to
california
they've got a covet issue now with aj
dylan who tested positive so they're
going to be worried about that
how many other guys are going to test
positive because dylan was on the
sideline throughout most of the game
on sunday maybe other guys are infected
maybe there's an opportunity
to to get the packers when they're a
little wobbly on a short week maybe
whatever
got into them on sunday against the
vikings is still there so
you know you got kyle's not going
concede no he's gonna he's gonna bust
his ass even harder
to try to win this game on thursday
night no definitely in fact i think it
stinks for kyle that the game's on
thursday night though you know
it takes another three extra days of
kyle again
to lose that few extra hours of
creativity and scientific you know
science scientist type of stuff and
you know they do match up really well
with green bay they really do
in a lot of ways it's not a good
match-up i mean i even still with all
these injuries
i mean i i would expect them to play
them very close you know there's great
familiarity here i mean of course matt
lafleur came from
kyle shanahan's coaching tree shanahan
coached with mike pettin
when he was the head coach of the
cleveland browns shanahan was the oc
so that's why part of the reason why i
believe he had his way with them last
year
he knows them better than they know him
and he was able to expose some of the
things that they do
but yeah i think they're still going to
be you know a pain in the butt really
good
in the conversation but man i just when
you lose that many good players i just
don't know if you can grind out
consistent wins week after week after
week and that's where it'll be tough
and it's not like their schedule is easy
either you know you got the same
yeah go ahead let's let before we before
we do
before you do the thing that would be
called out on bingo
let's remember what happened
the last time the 49ers and the packers
got together
in january 285 rushing yards
for the san francisco 49ers that day
eight passes thrown
by bob greasy i mean jimmy garoppolo for
the san francisco 49ers
and look i know look
raheem moster who had 220 yards that day
is not there but
plug someone else in and off they go
jared mckinnon will be the guy
or or maybe jim michael hastie or
whoever whoever's healthy that day will
be the guy
uh and and they can continue to do it
look what dalvin cook did and i know
that
the best running back on the 49ers
roster isn't close to dalvin cook
but it's not about being emmett smith or
barry sanders or adrian peterson if
you're a 49ers running back it's about
running the plays that are called
and they're going to work and kyle's
going to come up
dial up last year's game plan rip
through that defense that defense is
already demoralized
they may not have aaron jones
offensively so i i just think that
that there's reason yeah for some
optimism here i'm not going to
automatically say the packers
go out there and knock out the 49ers i
think the 49ers are going to give them a
hell of a fight
and i think back to last year the more i
envisioned what happened last year right
maybe it maybe it's going to happen
again hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports